Hello! Welcome to Michael's Business Top Tips.
This time, we're looking at a very exciting business strategy: Blue Ocean Strategy.
What is it?
Well, this strategy argues that most companies are fighting in Red Oceans,...
...where they're competing for market share.
Now, the Red Ocean refers to the bloodshed during this fierce competition.
Blue Ocean is where you create a whole new market,...
...where in the beginning, there are no competitors.
This is a whole new way of thinking about business strategy.
While they're focusing on market share, where often you're competing on price or volume,...
...here, you have no competition to worry about.
Let's look at an example, Starbucks.
Before Starbucks, coffee shops mainly competed on who could offer the cheaper coffee...
...or the better quality coffee.
However, Starbucks changed the coffee industry business...
...by combining the comfortable atmosphere of a hotel lobby,...
...big sofas, and relaxed style with still cheaper prices coffee, and best quality.
By combining these factors, they've made a whole new kind of coffee shop experience.
And at the beginning, they have no competitors.
Apply this to your business.
Think what you and your competitors are doing the same way.
Don't just compete against them,...
...think of a whole new way of approaching your business.
A useful site to help you is blueoceanstrategy.com.
This site gives you lots of tools and tips to help you create your own Blue Ocean.
Thank you and good luck!